[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Do you ever wish to
create a very, very custom user
interface?
With Flutter you have access
to low level paint calls.
These are fast and
efficient, and let
you build slick graphics.
For example, the Material
ink ripple effect
is implemented using a circle.
First, add a CustomPaint
widget to your widget tree.
Give it a size and a painter.
Then implement your painter.
It's a simple class that extends
CustomPainter and implements
two methods--
paint and shouldRepaint.
The shouldRepaint method is
called when the CustomPainter
is rebuilt. You can
tell the framework
to reuse the previous
result of paint.
The paint method is where
you get your canvas,
and are free to draw.
You can draw lines, rectangles,
circles, arcs, paths, bitmap
images, nine patches--
even paragraphs of text.
And you have full control
on how to paint these--
colors, shaders,
blend modes, and more.
For more info on CustomPaint
and all the other widgets,
head to flutter.io.